[Music]
all right john
john is with us in detroit hey john how
are you
mr ramsey thanks for taking my call sir
sure what's up um
well i got a question for you um due to
a combination of
many different things uh my wife and i
found ourselves in about a hundred and
forty thousand dollars in debt um
we owe approximately 140 000 on our
house and i know we could turn around
and sell it
today for about 300 maybe a little bit
more than that
my question to you is would that be a
smart move
to sell the home pay off of our pay off
our debt
and where we would be debt free and
possibly rent for a year where we would
be able to save up
um we probably would be able to save up
about as much money
that we have in equity right now over
the course of the next year
why don't you just pay off the debt over
the course of the next year
uh yeah that's i'm trying that's kind of
what i've been juggling um
i i so what is your household income
um well between the two of us i would
say
uh right now it's about ten thousand
dollars now
it varies due to my job uh some
sometimes
ten thousand dollars a month which is a
hundred and twenty thousand dollars a
year
so you're going to pay taxes on 120 next
year
um yes and you're not gonna pay off 140
000 in one year then or save 140 000 in
one year either
you only made 120 that's mathematically
impossible right
right no i understand that what were the
unfortunate events john that caused
y'all to take on 140 000 in debt
uh about six years ago i started the
business uh made some very stupid
decisions that i've uh
learned from um i tried sending the
business over to
my partner a few years back he
ran the business down and in the process
i was stuck with about 65 000 in
loans that i had personally financed uh
for the business
and um i went to work for him during
that time
um and i didn't get paid in about 35 000
worth of work and before i went back to
work for them
after i sold the business i had a
emergency back surgery where i was off
work for 11 months with no income
okay so um so viral very quickly
so number one do you like your house
uh we do like our house okay we love the
air and number two let's sit down with
120 000
income and say how fast could you pay
off 140
my guess is the quickest would be about
two years that'd be 70 000 out of 120
leaving you 50 to live on
okay that sounds about right
um well uh right now we're paying out
about
6 800 a month in debt
okay but here listen to me if you make
120 000
you live on 50 that leaves 70. 70 a year
for two years is 140.
right and that that is that includes
what you're paying out in debt and so
forth
that if you move you don't have a house
payment you have rent it would be about
the same as your house payment wouldn't
it
correct yeah so there's no gain in your
cash flow by moving
except paying off these debts really
quickly and so
if you like your house unless you hate
your house i would fight and live on
beans and rice for two years
and pay off your debts by living on a
very tight budget
otherwise you have to look at your wife
and say these stupid butt business
decisions i made cost
caused us to lose our home right
and you will continue to hear that for
years
no potentially but here here's the other
thing john that is
that uh concerns me i want you to
revisit what caused you to get there
because i've had people that have sold
the house and cleaned up the mess
only to repeat the mess because it was
the habit
that caused them to get into that
situation so
psychologically i i think you can stay
in this house i think you guys can get
serious on paying this off
but you're going to have to make these
sacrifices and they're not going to come
easy
you right now have sell the house as the
quick fix that might not be the best
overall fix for you and your family
yeah i agree the one thing that helps me
make these kinds of decisions with folks
or myself for that matter john is i ask
myself ten years from today which of
what
which of these was the best decision
financially
was it keeping the home and fighting my
way through the debt or was it selling
the home getting rid of the debt and
then using that
the fact that the debt is gone to pile
up some cash and buy another house
typically keeping the home will lead you
to a bigger pile of money
than moving all the costs involved all
the another potential
screw up because you make a mistake on a
real estate deal you have a real mistake